Speaker 1: Okay. A sitting Florida representative,
Randy Fine, who represents the 53rd District
in Florida, threatened Joe Biden with gun
violence in the aftermath of the Uvalde, Texas,
shooting. You have a shooting. Okay. And then Joe
Biden wants to do something about gun violence.
And an elected official threatens Biden with guns.
He tweeted, quote, I have news for the
embarrassment that claims to be our
president. Try to take our guns and you'll learn
why the Second Amendment was written in the first
place. That's an elected official. Ladies and
gentlemen, he should be immediately removed
from office. The Secret Service should visit
him and have a nice chat. And he was confronted
about what he tweeted. And he kind of doubles
down weirdly now as a warning to people watching.
Randy Fine is extremely red in this video, just
as a heads up. Listen to this guy. What a doofus.
Speaker 2: Did you worry that scary
things would also maybe embolden those
who have mental problems? I think when
the president, the United States gets
on the day of a mass shooting and says he's
going to come and take people's guns away,
that's he. It seems to me that he he turned his
speech into a speech on gun control. It was hugely
inappropriate. It was hugely inappropriate
in that day. If they are going to start this,
they cannot expect us to sit silently while
they try to strip our Second Amendment.
Speaker 1: You know, it doesn't really help your
cause when Joe Biden says, hey, I don't know,
we still haven't really tried any gun safety
regulations. Maybe we should. For you to threaten
to shoot the president implicitly. It doesn't
really help your cause that we should be just
doing nothing about the gun element. Incredible.
Speaker 2: Right. So what do you think?
Speaker 1: All right. He's got to go. And
of course, as usual, they insist. Oh, it's
he's injecting politics. He's injecting politics.
These are decisions made by political figures.
How on earth do you address something
that politicians should deal with
without injecting politics? And of course, it's
used as a pejorative while you're injecting
politics. Oh, yeah? Well, it's a political issue.
Why is that bad? That should just be. I mean,
that would just be the reaction. Yeah, this is a
political issue. The people are coming to us as
politicians saying, please do something. So who
who should they go to? Are they going to go to,
I don't know, doctors to pass some law about guns?
It's an absurd situation. And even more absurd
is that this guy is trying to say it
would be really bad to take anyone's guns,
even though that's not what Joe Biden said. It
would be really bad to take people's guns and to
prove to you how bad of an idea it would be. I'm
going to threaten to use my gun on the president.
You're making the case that your guns should
be taken, sir. What a vile and disgusting guy.